you know how Lipscomb shooting pretty
well here
you know Michigan's shooting 62 percent
oh look at Howard Batman on the back and
finish what a play Wolverine to better
here's Chad Howard what a play
one more look
[Music]
[Applause]
Howard from the logo got him from the
logo the freshman
[Applause]
Dickinson with it look Michigan is 8-13
from the three-point line they were just
three of 20 against Michigan
Power drives and knocks down a runner
I'm not too critical on that I know that
there are offensive minded team and
their defenses are disrupted because
they switch them up I just think at
times you have to have that that's just
it just doesn't make any sense
[Applause]
look just fine for juwan's son Howard's
been outstanding averaging over 15
points a game oh what a move there and
he gets it to go he left two on the
floor
skip pass Baseline driving
to Howard fading and Ripton that's jet
Howard folks
folks of late with a cap injury played
one minute Tuesday starting for the
injured Thompson today oh wow
that three but
Bowie with a three on the pass with 54
all is Howard splits him picks it back
up and lays it off for Terrence Reed and
he's fouled first made two of the night
Penn State started over four from
two-point land
[Applause]
with the foul
go to Hunter Dickinson with the bloody
nose
it just got popped he doesn't care Jed
Howard and the foul
[Applause]
here's Howard so talented straightaway
power
good chances there for Minnesota
after the Miss free throw
powered against Carrington spins feeds
and scores
quietly that's a huge three
so that gives him a little bit more
cushion
on the other end
Chad Howard